what is happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch stranger things four
by five today i want to say a special
thank you to all who have joined our
patreon page for this series full-length
watch-alongs are you single with the
time code for this show over there for
super sexy rejects along with a bunch of
other shows that we cover at the same
tier reaction highlights exclusives for
some of them included also if you can't
do that leave a like
that'd be kind of you we'd appreciate it
please
subscribe
what
also subscribe and hit that notification
bell to get notified when the rest of
the stranger things reactions come out
and then boys at prepper thank you so
much for helping us get through this
week means a lot
[Music]
breaking bad
eleven
[Music]
thoughts and prayers my guy
nina
nia bruce nina who's nina
okay okay okay
this is the number number hey right here
wait the number hey look at me
yeah
we should get off the road
my guy all right get off the road
dead isn't he this is the worst man you
could have gotten into yeah man
the least
naked speakers man
i said i'm a [ __ ] they always destroy
everything when they search but wouldn't
that make it harder to find things ah
[ __ ]
i know she was just here
and if you want to live
you're gonna tell me where she is i mean
it didn't seem like the odds were good
he was gonna live did you get some rest
a little
good
have a feeling you're gonna need it
i really don't want him to die but it
just seems that way he is the warmest
presence on this show right now
and that alone makes me paranoid
ruth ruth he was coming back
oh 12 hours ago they got caught
[ __ ] this is like some freaking area 51
[ __ ] area 11.
okay here we go
how'd you afford all this
[Laughter]
aren't you unemployed and i mean before
your government salary couldn't have
been that great
yeah you'll have to forgive the staring
you're a bit of a celebrity down here i
am
oh yeah they hate it angela too
never would cheer when you hit her with
that escape
we call her nina
what is
it if we told you it would ruin the
surprise
no
way
present
no hello
perhaps in our time apart you may have
even grown to hate me oh
no all i've ever wanted to do
is to help you you still come across
freaking evil man yeah let us work
together again
you and i
got him oh
why don't you go back inside play nice
to the doctor
no don't have creepy guards
the more you move the more this is going
to hurt
god damn it
this is not how i wanted things to begin
but everything's going to be all right
you're home now
that scar it's all the devagarga left
him with he knows
he's got a cool guy's car now yeah
wow what an opener
this show's so cool
that makes me question whether or not i
want paul ryser delivered now now yeah
die paul ryan
hey horribly
the first thing eleven does when she
gets her powers back cancel
[Laughter]
i trusted you paul reiser specifically
you paul reiser yes
ah [ __ ]
nimrod antal
what i tell you american
no run
now is going to be much pain
the [ __ ] looks like the dark knight
rises doesn't it
it's
a great camera quality i have expect to
hear the chanting just
look at that
crazy yeah and the snow is always
reflecting particles of the upside down
yeah right literally yeah the negative
image of that
we both knew the risks both of us
are today
and we lost
joyce
i'm not choice
it's like a prison break thriller man
yeah
hi
this is not american airlines
it's going to get bit
what an shopping
i'm gonna need a food delivery like
really soon unless you want me going out
into the world no no no i don't do
what an [ __ ]
you know you're welcome here anytime
totally you're like family
really absolutely i want pops to get out
of the action because for all we're
worth
okay
[Laughter]
i just couldn't sleep
people kept blasting music in my ears
for some reason
i don't know if something was different
he seemed surprised almost like he
didn't want me there
maybe you infiltrated his mind he
invaded your mind right is it that big
of a leap to suggest you somehow wound
up in his like freddy krueger's boiler
room ha ha fine i'll call call that
freddy crew is this a window
yeah
stained glass with roses
yeah see i'm not so terrible after all
yeah well it helps that i've seen it
before
that generic window would say
i've seen it before many times
in many places it's pieces of a house
not just any house
you guys are so good at arts and crafts
seriously yeah first the maze
now this
oh my god did they shave her head no
gi jane
oh
what
[Music]
that is so messed up
way to traumatize her guys yeah jesus
what did you expect
is she in like a traumatic memory
look who finally decided to join us
someone's a sleepyhead this morning
where am i i guess you're still not
quite awake huh
am i in hawkins
[Music]
well well
look who finally decided to join us
what someone's a sleepyhead this morning
is this like a young brenner
oh man
well wow
[Laughter]
we shouldn't have just thrown her in
there like this she's gonna drown in
there no
she is going to swim
you are the jk simmons from whiplash in
the show man
that made you good what do you want got
results what do you want
you're one of the best in the world
thanks to me
this is so messed up this is so messed
up oh burying the cop himself just relax
okay
why do you just go to the van
and do your thing
purple pawn tree delight hey that would
just make me more paranoid
yeah that's his pen
what
unknown hero agent the numbers on the
pen
hey man i'm using that
what are you doing
[Music]
oh yeah
what is it
it's the number
he got his digits man
oh [ __ ] yeah
that's what they do here
you sick russians place your bets now
oh crap
that's what you do when you get a
monster on your hands yeah man these
days they broadcast them on the dark web
my wife diane she wanted a baby
sarah
it wasn't an easy death she
suffered
i knew the risk but i um
i hid them
you were right what you said last night
i knew the risks
breaking out of here but i did it anyway
a minute i sent for joyce and then i
sent four
i sentence her to death
nah man
everyone i love i hurt
see i was wrong this whole time
i wasn't cursed
i am the curse
speaking of
use that
you're right about one thing
we are going to die in here
i don't want enzo to die actually okay i
can't get over how beautiful the show
looks man i know
love the snow but i know chrissy's in
heaven now
but i also know she's frustrated that
the monster that did this to her is
still out there
excuse me guys i want to go check out
this clock really fast so weird over
there
the hellfire club
they're hiding eddie maybe we should
bring all this to the cubs the cops
would think chris is a drug dealer
what if they cursed us or some [ __ ]
patrick thinks he's cursed
let's take a break to bully this guy
you should have reefer rick's house to
this what
he's eddie supplier he's supposed to be
in prison but someone spotted him back
in this house it's probably nothing
i don't know no that's good
[ __ ] it daddy yeah damn it
ah [ __ ]
maxis
max is like the beverly
yeah yeah totally getting like knee bolt
house losers club vibes from it stephen
king
wherever we get those
do you need to be told everything
you're not a child
don't leave it i just want to leave the
backpack you don't leave anything
anywhere
you all see that right
yeah
is this what you saw ah
i heard you we're just always partners
okay what you have a problem with that
it'd just be nice to you know i don't
know mix it up a bit so what i'm
hoarding is that oh no
it's cool seeing that shot coming to
life like what were they staring at in
that photo yeah
the stranger things
you can't yeah
what
[Music]
oh my god you could use the peanut
butter cream and slip through the cuffs
yes
pour the glass and cut the rope
absolutely
even more effective
i take him who flies this plane all
right so don't knock him out just get
his gun and make him turn us around
eddie's gun just like that huh is black
not the highest color
you're a liar i've never fought in a
real world scenario oh no
[Music]
a great mix of the score well
look who finally decided to join us
oh
she's getting mad she's gonna figure
this out
the recording says 9479
break the mirror
confront the past and break me
whoa
wicked oh oh my god that's eerie yeah oh
that's so eerie
look who finally decided to join us
someone's a stupid smart
i'm sorry
wow
training starts any minute now this is
okay
hey
there's nothing to be nervous about that
is so creepy yes
this is an expensive show yep
feared
[Music]
fascinating ah it's really fascinating
listen to this
does that remind you of anything
war games huh hmm we're calling a
computer
okay i don't know if nina's a computer
like joshua or owen's lab but unknown
cure agent man he gave us access to it
for a reason
music
i just need a hat the only hacker that i
know lives
in utah oh my god
[Music]
turn around
yes
it's time
oh
even better they've upgraded the suits
the smoking
saucepan
it's him
he doesn't you there it's eddie you
remember me right hey uh
anyone's there i really think i might be
in a bit of trouble here okay
wheeler
anybody oh i hope vacna kills that one
guy so they can see
yeah
what the hell
oh stephen steve
what's wrong this is a spider what dater
is just
i guess we should
get back to the investigation
the obvious things are not what
people
observe or down up sir
or
sherlock holmes
best boy steve harrington best boy
eleven
versus chapter two no stranger things
yeah for days it's a great effect of the
[ __ ]
it's well chosen
[Music]
i'll make it move
waste of time
god no wonder she killed all you kids
just bullies every step of her life
this reminds me of the cell
good call
[Music]
wow
what a crazy shot swim faster okay
that's enough pour out
no or else
[Music]
oh no
you are fragile cargo you can still pray
not if i break you first
my fingers are like arrows
my arms like iron get to it but turn
this plane around and i will spay your
life
he used the scarf
oh my god jesus joyce
[Applause]
oh
god
damn this fight's getting a lot crazier
than i expected
fingers are like arrows yeah
my arms like iron
oh
no
now learn to fly at the plane
what are you doing
wow
oh
bad
that was really expensive that
that did look very expensive
i got him
oh i got him
i had him
whoa
oh i think he's moving he's moving he's
moving
cool creative
i lost him
maybe max leading isn't the
brightest idea
crank that music up
guys
what if he's leading us into a trap
guys
guys
dude i was about to say what's happening
with eddie
dustin
please
are you there
if someone witnesses him die
that could really save them
oh buddy
oh my [ __ ] god
oh god damn they're fast
yeah
they're going to college on a squid mix
dollar skip that's a cerebral room
[Music]
he's 100 here
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
oh good
this is just what they needed oh no
oh
jesus christ
air
get some air for christ's sake
it's okay it would take time to adjust
[Music]
these hot head shots man
nah you can escape this time
come on come on
you can just feel it coming oh i was
like let's go
god i love this season remarkable
no
he does know how to bring it out i said
stay away
oh no is this still part of the tank
thingy
you didn't think it would be that easy
deformation did you
oh you're gonna make her choose
daughter
unfortunately tasha'll get her powers
back
[Music]
[ __ ]
sucks but that's i know
like let's go one scene longer i know
what's going on
i feel like there's like another one
here
yeah oh
this is a great season i love this
season so far yeah this is spectacular
papa can you hear me
that's the 11th song when she needs a
song this season
oh my gosh
what a [ __ ]
superhero way to bring back a villain
i know
like unfortunately he's the only one who
can help
yeah
such a superhero thing
hey and i mean that's this episode we've
been watching a lot that was this
episode when he came back right
oh in the present day brenner
yeah yeah that wasn't the last episode
was this one i think it was this one
the thing about binge tv i mean it does
yes it does it can write i mean and i
don't even think that's
bad entirely i mean yeah for for
discussing the confines of a singular
episode yes but i feel like the binge
format is designed to just make you
think of it like one long story but yeah
i think this is the one where it
confirmed that it is the present day he
is still here yeah yeah yeah they're on
the road guy dies yeah
um yeah what a what a brilliant way to
do that
again this show just loves dealing with
drama yeah so much so just rip all those
woods back open everyone's just haunted
by their past and it's like the upside
down
constantly reflects
um
some semblance of of
uh
traumatic wounds yes whatever's ailing
these people is alive and personified
somewhere in the upside down
even down down to the creation or at
least the the awareness of
not victor creole the uh
beckham
velcro
uh back now you know just this whole
manifestation where he lives is such a
place of one man's
i don't know why there is where he's
choosing to lay camp
or if not chosen a lake camp for some
reason that's just the grounds in which
he must reside but that also is a place
for you know that resembles another
man's trauma like everyone's just so
this whole thing is just a big traumatic
thing and then hopper lamenting about
all the the pains he's had to endure
that's i i don't recall ever getting
like a clear story of you know having to
please his dad and going off to war and
all that like we explored sarah in
season one a lot and that's obviously
bled through with
uh his relationship with eleven
but we haven't uh i don't think we got
that much past
history so it's just it's cool it's cool
how they're doing this you know with
brenda coming back you're like guys
still
you don't trust him but he is the one to
get the goddamn job done
yeah the perfect like eerie 80s sci-fi
doctor where you're like not everything
is good and right with you but
unfortunately you're the expert yeah
you're the only one who yeah
begrudgingly he represents that sinister
line of science where it's like this is
the cost for the advances you want i
don't know what to tell you and to have
eleven shoes at the end it was great
mm-hmm really great yeah going back to
him like she like she knows now yeah
that in order for her to get activated
and to come to her fullest potential i
have to accept this
yeah yeah oh
boy
it's great that's great yeah yeah
unfortunate because you know like i want
her to have one scene with paul reiser
where she sees that paul ryser really
does care still yeah he's the one who's
always he's the only leading pull around
no what are you doing dude this is not
the right way to do this
like he needs to see that he's not a
dick not total dick you know yeah
yeah and i mean you know i i really love
the way that they did the back and forth
of that and the way that they really put
you in the shoes of her distrust the
whole time and i thought that was a good
reversal with paul reiser because he is
up until that point such a warm sweater
he's the one person who shows up and
you're like i i think i feel a little
more comforted because of what you're
saying and then here it's like even he
is not a perfect figure or perfectly
benevolent figure in that i mean
somewhere down the line he had to know
that this was going to be the way that
this had to go um and yeah
they're really really great i think at
using these longer episodes to give you
really wonderful character pieces
because yeah with hopra it struck me
literally i was like we haven't really
delved into his history as a character
aside from the stuff with sarah that
we've gotten a microscope on and just to
get that monologue he's a cop in new
york too i think at some point yeah but
but that whole thing about agent orange
and and you know going overseas and
and and you know
all that
nastiness because yeah it's like that
agent orange is like such a horrific and
such a sort of black mark on our history
and it's something that affected so many
people in such a horrific way
and yeah like to really kind of uh inc
nothing's that bad
yeah you know monsanto is still around
making chemicals that we use every day
so really it can't have been that
but uh yeah like like getting those
little try getting a reaction up on time
yeah but uh i thought that in you know
what what could have and i guess
cynically if you don't like it you could
call it an info dump but it's it is like
a a really rich monologue that did
remind me like we've been calling out
these references but it reminded me
something more like a hill house side of
netflix where it's like yeah you're just
getting this performance and for as much
as hop's story has been so physical i
really loved
that
really emotional and all that played
really close up in his face and using
that as also a way to kind of bridge
something of a gap between him and enzo
uh and it makes me all the more uh
worried for when he returns because you
know vectors obviously the whole thing
is preying on people's unr uh resolved
traumas and like hopper is just all
under solved trauma
yeah
but you know like they they find
that's what they mean they find
hope within each other this group of
people and they all inevitably come
together in the end yeah and maybe
that'll just like blow vechna's battery
entirely
way too much trauma guys the way they
the way they're tying stuff back in so
much to all these other seasons it's
like you got the doctor from season one
and the doctor from season two now
teaming up together yeah the dcu
yeah dr cinematic universe they're good
at making it feel all encompassing while
also not making it
what's this door hi hi babes
shut the door yeah yeah they're good at
making it feel all-encompassing without
uh well when and and having that feel
like a natural part of the unfolding
story and having it feel like just a
natural world populated by these
characters instead of it being like ah
remember yeah
yeah
yeah it's like i don't even remember
sarah being brought up at all in season
three
[Music]
um
oh yeah because you got all that stuff
with them trying to build this you know
surrogate father-daughter relationship
there and then
i i got it sorry so you can see no yeah
it just made i think here was a very
natural place to kind of have that all
collected then
because you know that whole thing about
like i needed them you know i needed
joyce and i needed jane
11. yeah you know
what there's if there's one thing that i
i'm a tad
as i root for hopper and joyce a lot um
if there is one thing i'm a tad let down
by this show on
is um
winona ryder specifically
because especially revisiting the show i
totally forgot like when nope a writer
was like the main character in the first
season and she was just so richly ridden
and she's still great in season two uh
but like season one like she was you
know she was the only one who never gave
up on will like a lot of people were
like doubting and stuff but she always
believed and she was looked at as the
crazy one but she wasn't crazy she
finally vindicated it yeah it was great
and it seems like since season three
they're like let's let's make her paired
up with the another a guy making like
funny stuff
yeah make a character significantly
lighter let's make her more bubbly yeah
which is fun to watch but yeah i feel
like maybe one aspect of the season that
doesn't benefit certain characters at
least is the idea it's funny because i
just saw a quote by millie bobby brown
and the guy who plays will talking about
how there are so many characters and
they're like you should start killing
some of these people more
because while i you know certainly don't
want any characters that we love to exit
it is the sort of thing where yeah
characters who were introduced later for
for a large part seem to be having more
of the emotional uh you know
zoomings in
and extrapolations which makes sense
because we've spent more time with
certain characters however it does seem
like there is then a sort of sliding of
you know joyce is more of just an active
character for the plot rather than
having an emotional journey beyond just
like we gotta get hopper back and this
is kind of a madcap adventure
um and i don't dislike watching it's
very similar to season three with her
too yeah exactly and so
it's one of those things where it's like
i recognize you don't have all the time
and joyce and murray is a bubbly fun duo
but at the same time yeah
she doesn't feel like as much of a
character in certain other like even
steve like i love steve but it seems
like steve's whole thing this season is
to stand around and and either say what
we would say yeah or you know be in in
kind of
every now and again he'll have this like
little friction with dustin
and you know then we move on and it's
like i'm happy to have you but i want
something for your character
i mean there's still
if i'm not mistaken the last episode's
like an hour and a half
maybe longer actually i think it's like
an hour 40 something something like that
it's really long and then
the last two
like the real last two and part two
comes out
are two episodes but it's like five
hours so it's like it's like a
ridiculous amount of time yeah it's like
back-to-back giant movies yeah yeah yeah
which is uh interesting um so yeah those
last two are massive
so i imagine there's gonna be time to
really you know flesh out it's not the
final season but it's interesting how
they treat this show this this
particular season is in a lot of ways i
keep feeling like it sort of feels like
this could be a final season and then
the way things are going yeah yeah and
there's going to be a season five after
part two right to wrap it all up okay
and uh yeah i mean i think like the mike
and will and jonathan and
argyle yes
there's some there's there's some fun to
be had there but yeah i mean undoubtedly
the the truly interesting stuff comes
with the other stories hopper
what's going on with um you know [ __ ]
the vechna
and everyone they're involved with the
vector story yeah hopper and everyone of
all the vacuums that's the truly
engaging stuff everyone kind of
surrounding max and eddie
yeah you know in the in the thick of
things and two i guess it's also that
you you kind of can see like they've
been pretty decent whenever we've at
least for me looking back across these
episodes thus far it going whenever i'm
like i want to see more of this or or
you know what about that thing kind of
coming back into sharper focus and they
tend to answer those quandaries in the
next episode
um and there is i think you can tell by
looking at some of those plot lines it's
like maybe they're spreading it's like
for example it's like the will and mike
and jonathan all them
you know they're
i feel like they kind of have to take
that plot and kind of spread it out more
in smaller chunks than other plots you
know so i can still see that culminating
into something that feels that by the
end of the season you know reasonably
plugged in and satisfying and i think
right now maybe we're just in a position
where that plot line for everything they
have in their bible for this season
probably just isn't as substantial as
the others and so it's getting kind of
pared out in you know wider
chunks and you can see that with certain
characters and certain stories that we
do check in with just once or twice an
episode i feel like finn wolfhard and
winona ryder
were
like
two like
um just flat out amazing characters in
season one and they were such a focus it
was like they were such a like there's a
big ensemble usually have a cup a few
primary leads and they were like primary
leads
and then it seems like after that
they've slowly been
running out like genuine things to
explore with them yeah
it
yeah it feels like we got to a place
where their stories were completed and
now we don't really know what to do with
their emotional arcs as much i mean
there is the thing with mike and ellen
and love yeah but beyond that yeah it
feels like
they've they're they're done you've got
to focus on other characters oh yeah and
11 stuff is really interesting too yeah
yeah yeah
and i mean the 11th stuff this episode
was was really
really gripping and reminded me of you
know a lot of other different things
especially night episode four moon night
episode four moon on episode five five
yeah a little sprinkle a little bit like
the black rainbow on top and then
moonlight invented that yeah
yeah
thank you marvel thank you bart you
changed the game
but even that like you know i know we
were going back and forth on like the
de-aging stuff and i thought that here
they used it conscientiously enough and
i like that they kept doing the splicing
back and forth because it's jarring but
it also i think gives your brain less
time to focus in on the effect and
nitpick it and uh yeah the way that they
make that sort of psychological
experiments like it really does fit in
not only with the horror and everything
but you know that sort of uh mk ultra
government conspiracy kind of thing that
has always area 51 yeah yeah yeah yeah
and that's you know something that's
always been a part of the show but i
think i especially associate with season
one because it is so kind of again like
shady government conspiracy thing and so
yeah like being back in that cold
environment and having those pangs from
the past but also just the jarring
you know updates from the here and now
present i think are really visceral and
really engaging
um yeah they why they made everyone
meaner to
l so that way you feel less bad where
she goes and says like every mob of
young people is [ __ ] that make you
feel less bad
yeah maybe they don't deserve to maybe
all these conservative dicks they're all
kind of mean yeah but it also ties into
her how she's dealing with bullies again
you know in her school life that angela
story is never going to be i hope she
goes back
so it has to be the final scene of this
whole show yeah whole series season five
finale yeah goes back freaking just
obliterates
well the stuff with eddie and
what's basketball player saying
jason i want to say
um
yeah because i was thinking oh i mean
this kid's got to die in front of him so
that way he can see that you know like
that's how chrissy died but now i'm
thinking
well
what if the guy's like oh my god curse
real he did you yeah
kill him i'm honestly thinking they
might go there now
it's either that or they're going to be
an unlikely duo and i think each is as
likely as the other because i mean yeah
i almost i've i've learned especially
from anime and two-part doctor who
episodes that if anything looks too
optimistic at the end of one it will be
non-optimistic at the beginning of the
other or vice versa
so in that moment i was like maybe he
will believe
but then also i think they could go for
a nice little subversion there or
something why do none of you talk about
what's happening
i know guys come on
open up
is it because back then you know like
talking about the things we get thrown
in the loony bit that's right
that's right well hey i mean you know
apparently it's only still a select few
of people who know all the things that
happen in hawkins
so they would be just locked up like
man yeah they would all just become
creels at that point i guess
but yeah this was uh still good i still
i still would not want them written out
you know like mike and will and all that
um no because every time they do
something with their character all their
like little
bonding moments i'm like yeah more well
i think the i think the plot of what
that's going on is more interesting than
the character stuff sometimes to me
which is uh
kind of sad because it's got to go it's
kind of kind of be like
equal you know it's going to do like the
character stuff and the plot of what
whoever we're with that has to be
just as engaging uh i feel like this
depends yeah i feel like they spend
what brooch is on equal time investing
in both
especially because these episodes are
longer but i feel like they don't do as
much to spread the emotional beats as
judiciously so it's like you get some
really satisfying ones with certain
characters and then you get other ones
that are a little bit more just like
yeah this is kind of basic they're just
kind of mending their friendship i guess
yeah you know
well what i think is neat is that if you
watch stranger things as a like a
complete package
i feel like the the most constant
lead has been 11
out of
11 and hopper have been have been the
most consistent strong leads
like as a leading character
then
and uh
if you watch all the stranger things as
a package what i think is cool is like
sometimes other people are not that lead
and now those leads are there to support
these other characters who are now going
to take the spotlight yeah yeah like max
is especially max's got a lot of
attention in season two but it's here
especially she's like oh you're you're
more
you're more uplifted here yeah you know
you you your circumstances tie you more
directly into the main part of what's
going on yeah exactly yeah whereas like
the season two is like you're the new
girl you're mad max and you got a you
mean brother
is abusive
it's really tied to the weird parts of
stranger things but it's when you're
here yeah and i like you yeah and then
now uh
very significantly like her she her
association with all this it's it so i
think that's a cool part of it is even
though i'll find myself craving more i'm
like but at least you know season one
had they were it was these guys season
two was these guys season three it was
then where levin and hopper seem to be
like the most consistent in terms of
giving them something
truly juicy to sink their teeth into
yeah you know i feel like you can always
extrapolate on those two to the degree
yeah
and they are like
the heart too
um lost the daughter that's the father
come together to meet in the middle yeah
and just see somebody goes together all
right guys well thanks for being here
you know when i last thought when hopper
did have that speech it did make me i
missed david harper's voice i know i
forgot about it i know ripping voice
that david harper has said yeah and when
he's just staring off from the distance
and telling his story like yeah i was
like i'll do like a mike flanagan just a
hopper monologues episode
because also too i mean what they wrote
for him was great like that flashback i
felt like we learned so much more about
this guy than we have been so long yeah
yeah
all righty well
thanks for being able to talk soon guys
the ogre man dude i am so glad you
pledged towards the end of the month
because
i myself consider me to be an ogre man
as well
let's face it us ogre men
we are delicious oh yeah we are a rare
breed
some people go ooh
ogre
gross you're like onion yeah
you smell bad yeah i understand the
reference
shrek
yeah
yeah max schreck from the batman returns
i get where you're getting it i get the
references man yeah so ogre man i want
you to know
that dude
if you're feeling like being an ogre
means
you have to hide yourself from the world
don't
because you know what times are changing
dad bods are in
when did that become a thing
now you can be out of shape a little bit
and be hot
the next stage
is being an ogre now yeah
so dude your time awaits you
there's just going to be so many oh
graces
which i believe is the female term for
are gonna be coming after you now
lunging themselves seeking their ogre
teeth those green yellow stained
things
into your neck it's gonna be delicious
it's raining ogre so ogre man you are
indeed a super sexy reject and don't you
forget it
i want the record to show that your name
on our patreon is ogre man so i don't
know who you really are
but i've been in this situation before
and
i have no idea what you look like who
you really are you look like a pixie i'm
just going off of your name and i hope
you know that i'm just joking here
you could be the least like an ogre out
of anybody's reals it's possible but if
you truly suffer with some kind of
you know insecurity about your physical
appearance
know that none of what i said was rooted
in
that
because i simply have nothing to go off
of nope let the record show
that is the case not even a profile pic
send us a profile
so what i'll say is thank you for being
here
and i hope to god you have a sense of
humor because if you're gonna be an ogre
in this world
you're gonna have to be funny in order
to get some people to like you
because you're basically your looks are
not going to do you justice it's going
to drive everyone away from you unless
you can learn how to be funny
go to comedy school take an improv class
write a stand-up set see you soon thanks
for being here go to your first shout
out
[Music]